>> WHAT DO YOU DO WHEN HATERS
PUSH FEARS ABOUT YOUR NEXT
HORRIBLE MOVE?
YOU TROLL THEM WHICH IS THAT
TRUMP DID TO THE NERVOUS NANCIES
PRETTY HE MAY NEVER LEAVE
OFFICE.
IF HE LOSES HE WON'T GO.
I SAID SINCE BEFORE HE GOT
ELECTED.
>> IF HE LOSES, TRUMP, HE WON'T
GO.
I SAID THAT SINCE BEFORE HE GOT
ELECTED.
>> CRAZY!
IT'S PURE PROJECTION.
WE HAVE BEEN CRUSHING BILL IN
THE RATINGS.
HE IS GOING NOWHERE.
HE THOUGHT AMENDMENT 22 WAS A
TINY HANDGUN.
IT'S A LAW THAT SETS TERM
LIMITS.
THIS FANTASY THAT TRUMP WON'T
LEAVE IS LIKE JUSSIE SMOLLETT
CLAIMING HE WON'T LEAVE
"EMPIRE."
TRUMP HAD SOME FUN AND TWEETED
THAT HIS SUPPORTERS DEMAND I
STAY LONG.
A 3rd TERM OR MORE.
THIS TEASES HIS CRITICS AND GETS
AT THEIR REAL FEAR THAT THEY
CAN'T BEAT HIM.
THAT HE WON'T GO AFTER THE FIRST
BUT THE SECOND TERM MEANING
THERE WILL BE MORE.
TRUMP CRITICS ARE GETTING THE
PUBLIC TO THINK PAST THE
REELECTION.
IT'S LIKE A CAR SALESMAN TALKING
ABOUT A TRIP UP THE COAST WHEN
YOU ARE STILL LEAVING IN KANSAS.
THE KEY IS IN YOUR HAND AND
TRUMP IS BEHIND THE WHEEL AND
WAITING FOR 2024.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> DANA, THANK YOU.
I WILL GO TO YOU FIRST FOR
COMPLIMENTING ME.
>> THAT WAS A REAL GOOD SEGMENT.
>> TRUMP KNOWS HOW TO HAVE FUN
WITH CRITICS?
>> WHAT HAPPENED TO ME?
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THAT'S UNFAIR.
>> FORGET THESE TWO.
I AM KIDDING.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO ANSWER FIRST?
>> THEY ARE DOING THIS BECAUSE
THEY NEED A NEW CONSPIRACY
BECAUSE COLLUSION DIED.
THEY NEED THIS TO JUSTIFY THE
IMPEACHMENT PUSH.
HE WON'T LEAVE IF HE BEAT HIM SO
IMPEACH HIM.
THEY ARE ADMITTING THAT THE
MEDIA TRIED ALL THEY CAN TO NAIL
THIS GUY AND TAKE HIM OUT.
EVEN IF SOMEONE DOES BEAT HIM AT
THE BALLOT BOX HE WON'T LEAVE.
THIS IS WHY ALL OF THE STUFF WE
THREW AT HIM WAS NOT GOING TO
WORK ANYWAY.
HE IS SO TOUGH AND NASTY AND
DIRTY THAT NOTHING WOULD HAVE
WORKED.
THAT'S WHY EVERYTHING WE THREW
AT HIM DIDN'T WORK.
THIS IS BASED ON POLLS COMING
OUT THAT ARE SHOWING TRUMP
LOSING TO BUTTIGIEG OR
SOMETHING.
SOME THINGS WERE TWEETED FOR
CONTEXT.
JUNE 1983.
MONDALE UP 10 POINTS ON RAG
RAN -- REAGAN.
AND GEORGE H.W. BUSH BEAT AN
UNNAMED DEMOCRAT BY 30 POINTS.
DOLE BEATING CLINTON AND KNOWN
2001, AN UNNAMED REPUBLICAN
SMOKING BARACK OBAMA.
IT'S VERY EARLY SO KEEP OUR
POWDER DRY.
>> THINKING PAST THE SALE?
THEY ARE DOING THAT BY ACCIDENT.
>> YOU THINK TRUMP IS TROLLING
THE DEMOCRATS BY HIS TWEET AND
WE SHOULD NOT TAKE IT SERIOUSLY?
>> YEAH.
>> I THINK TRUMP IS HIGHLY
UNPREDICTABLE.
I HOPE YOU AGREE.
>> YES, DO I.
>> HE SAID HE WOULD VIOLATE THE
LAW BY TAKING INFORMATION FROM
FOREIGN COUNTRIES FOR AN
ELECTION WHICH IS A FELONY.
>> NOT TRUE.
>> THAT'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> NO.
>> NOTHING IS OUT OF BOUNDS WHEN
IT COMES TO TRUMP.
HE MAY BE TROLLING, BUT I WILL
SAY THIS MUCH IN RESPONSE TO
JESSE.
HE FIRED POLLSTERS WHO TOLD HIM
HE MIGHT BE LOSING.
>> NO THE ONES HE THOUGHT LEAKED
IT.
>> THAT'S PART OF THE WHOLE
TEAM.
>> YOU FIRE LEAKERS.
>> HE IS UPSET ABOUT THIS.
IF HE HAD NOT SAID EVER THE
ELECTION IF HE LOST TO HILLARY
CLINTON HE MIGHT NOT ACCEPT THE
ELECTION RESULTS, I WOULD SAY
NO.
BOTH SIDES ARE BEATING EACH
OTHER.
>> YOU DON'T BELIEVE HE WILL
STAY IF HE LOSES?
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR HIM TO STAY.
>> EVERY DAY YOU AND GREG SAY
THE POWER OF TRUMP SUPPORTERS IS
SUCH THEY MAKE EXCUSES FOR
WHATEVER.
IF HE SAID THIS ELECTION WAS
RIGGED --
>> IF TRUMP REFUSES TO LEAVE
OFFICE, I WON'T DEFEND THAT.
>> THANK YOU!
>> [LAUGHING].
>> WHAT I FIND INTERESTING ABOUT
THIS DELUSION IS HOW LITTLE
INVESTMENT MOST NORMAL PEOPLE
HAVE IN THIS WHOLE SITUATION.
IF TRUMP GETS REELECTED, I AM
COOL WITH IT.
IF HE IS NOT, OH WELL.
I HAD 4 YEARS OF TRUMP WHICH WAS
A HILARIOUS PHENOMENON WE WON'T
SEE AGAIN.
IT'S NOT AN EMOTIONAL EVENT FOR
YOU.
YOU HAVE A CAR AND A JOB.
>> I DO.
I THINK IT'S SO RIDICULOUS THAT
THE WHAT IF, 2 TO 6 YEARS FROM
NOW IS SOMETHING THAT IS LIKE
COVERED BY THE NEWS.
THE WASHINGTON EXAMINER SAID
IT'S A SUPER SERIOUS PROSPECT WE
SHOULD ALL BE WORRIED ABOUT AND
START PREPARING FOR.
TRUMP REFUSING TO LEAVE THE
WHITE HOUSE OR NUCLEAR WAR?
THAT COULD FIT IN THERE?
>> THEY ARE A CONSERVATIVE
PAPER.
>> BECAUSE IT WAS AN OPINION.
ANYWAY, IT'S RIDICULOUS AND
WASTING EVERYBODY'S TIME.
>> THE WEIRD THING THESE ARE NOT
DUMB PEOPLE SAYING THESE ABSURD
THINGS.
IT'S LIKE SATANIC RITUALS AT
DAYCARE CENTERS.
IT OVERCOMES YOU.
>> THE REASON I COMPLIMENTED YOU
IS IN THEIR HEARTS OF HEARTS
THEY KNOW HOW HARD IT IS TO BEAT
AN INCUMBENT PRESIDENT.
THEY SAY THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE
IS UNFAIR AND THERE WILL BE
VOTER SUPPRESSION.
THIS IS ACTUALLY A 3rd THING
THEY CAN ADD TO IT.
>> I THINK IF HE LOSES --
>> DO YOU THINK HE WANTS TO COME
BACK TO NEW YORK?
>> I JUST DID THIS JOB AND I
WILL DO SOMETHING ELSE.
IT'S ABOUT A NEW HOTEL.
THEN HE WILL GO PLAY GOLF.
>> HE WILL NEVER STOP BEING
VOCAL.
>> HE WILL GET AN HOUR ON FOX.